At Udacity sometimes we have a little bit too much fun making memes.
In fact I just searched for
meme and all of these plus a lot more showed up in my inbox.
We apparently send these out all the time.
In fact one time James even sent out an entire email about
the programming language Swift using Taylor Swift memes.
So we, yeah, probably have too much fun.
I hear this one came out of web performance because I'm
making kind of a funny face.
No idea where this one came from but
that's Jared who makes classes at Georgia Tech.
This is Ben who's favorite thing in the world is to make Chrome extensions.
In fact, it comes up in almost every conversation about some type of
new technology.
Ben'll be like, hey, I could make a Chrome extension for that.
So of course, I had to make a meme about him.
But I think my all-time favorite meme in my inbox is this one.
To give you a little bit of background we have Fancy Friday every other Friday,
where instead of trying to dress up like normal tech workers, who are always
wearing jeans and T-shirts, we try to put on something different, you know?
Wear something nice.
And this is David in the background here.
And I don't know what's going on here.
Apparently this is fancy.
But who knows?
So I've gone ahead and shown you some of our favorite memes.
But now we want to know what your favorite meme is.
Go ahead hop on the forums and post your favorite safe for work memes.
When you're done check this box to keep going.